foreign
Northeast India's manipul state is
ninhoiho dorka's home for the
foreseeable future
she moved here after the ethnic violence
flared up in May with no access to a
university books or even the internet
Dorcas is worried about completing her
degree
the 20 year old is studying to be a
doctor and had to travel to a
neighboring state to sit for exams
we don't even get a chance to take out
our books from our homes we just came
out from our homes we just do clothes
and with our bags and here too since
many people are staying here we can't
concentrate on our studies anymore and
we are full of tension
activists accuse the government of
denying people their basic rights and
the internet blackout has only worsened
the situation that Society there has
regressed to a feudal order which is
pre-digitization does not mean that you
are not being able to access Netflix it
means for a lawyer they are not able to
access the cause list of the Manipur
High Court it means for people they
cannot draw their pensions properly
access their net banking for young
children to actually access the
educational content which is made
available
at this Front Line Cookie volunteer
stand guard they include young men like
satgung kipjin who traded his studies
for the trenches they fear being
attacked by the May face if they leave
their posts
trouble and money pull began three
months ago when a court recommended
extending state benefits granted to the
minority cookies to the majority mateys
the violence has killed more than 150
people and displaced tens of thousands
of families because of this war we can't
even study properly and we have to stay
a whole day whole night we have to in
Bunker
so that our parents our
brother and sister could still
peacefully
Haitian Ministry says more than 14 000
children have been displaced to keep
young people busy this football coach
has stepped in and is offering training
just by having some time to play Lets
them believe they have a future even the
parents are happy to bring them here it
keeps their mind off things
as the standoff between the cookies and
the methane shows no sign of being
resolved young people on both sides are
hoping they won't be forgotten
Sharif Al Jazeera